ας που δεν αφορά τη σχέση μου με των κύριοων αναστασιάδην αλλά των συμβούλον με
πολιτικά πρόσωπα λιγότερες συμβουλεσις ακούονται και περισσότερες δεν ισακμ αι του το εν το έρω
το δεύτερο είναι ακόμα και συμβουλές που ισακούονται πως εκτελούνται ίναι απαραίτητα το ίδιο άρα
ναι θα έλεγα ότι στην περίπτου σην οονίκος αναστασία της είχε στιγμές που άκουε και
ακουγε καλά έναν άλλον προσόν τουνίκου αναστασιάτηταν ότι άκογε πολούς είχε τ όταν ή θέλε
να διαμορφώσει άποψη και απόφαση όχιτε υπήρχε περιπτώσεις που προεγυπτερε ένα θέμαν και το ένστιχτών
του το πολιτικών του ελεγενώ ότι πριακάουμε έτσι άρα ότι και να του ελεγείες λίγες
πιθανότητες είχαν αν ήταν διαφορετικών απααυτόν που είχε ν αποφασίσει αλλά σε παράπολλες περιπτώσης άκουγια
κια που γεν πάρα πολικοςέκλευε κάτι που του υπενόθησεας κτί που το πενόχακεη κύρι κοσκατί
που το υπενοχή οψι και στο τέλος διαμόρφωνα το δικόν του τηδική του ισύγηση μή
απόφαση εσύ περίμενες ότι θα βγάζε το ιβλίον το ηκοφάντι πριν κικλοφορισενώ περίμενες όι θα
απαντήσειμε αυτό των τρόπο σου διαμορφώσο λίγο διαφορετικά την ερώτηση νε περίμενα ότι θα αποφάσεις
δε νυγάνι ένα βιβλίων όχι και προσωπικά θεωρώ ότι αδική των έ αυτόν του με
τον περιορίζει δέκα χρόνια διακυβέρνησης στη διάρκεια της οποίας εγίνα σημαντικότατα πρργματα έγινε το γεση
ημείωση της θητίαση στην εθνική φρουράντοτρία έψηλον παρέλαβες μια χώρακουρεμένει και κατάφερες να γυρίσει στην
οικονονία δικο να τα αφήνεις όλα αυτά στην πάντα και ένα σχολίσεμε κάτι το ευτελές
αν μου επιτρέπεται θεωρω ότι τα λλάθος του δεν ρώτησε στης